[Music]
awesome perfect so all right welcome
back everyone to another prepare like a
pro lecture
um today I wanted to show
two of my games
an aggressive approach against the
English opening so
many of you might know about this move
but
the English opening has been
increasingly popular lately I would say
um
especially at the Grand Master Level and
the reason being that probably because
the E4 and D4 responses are getting
a lot of repetitive lines and sometimes
white wants to
um
play something a little bit more
interesting and keep it as flexible as
they can so C4 is
very common and
I have some ideas that might be
interesting
um maybe not in the main main lines but
definitely in some of the sidelines that
I have faced myself in practice so yeah
I said two games and I will get started
so both of those games will be starting
with the move E5 I have played this
basically throughout my lifetime
um many many players can prefer other
lines like Knight F6
E6 or E5 which is what I played or
something like C5 C6 or many other lines
possible but E5 is basically playing the
Reversed Sicilian and this is very
important to kind of understand because
we already declare that we want to play
something sharp rather than something
though
my opponent played Knight C3
I played Knight F6 and this is a game I
played I forgot to mention against
um I believe feed the master Seth homa
in the world open and I don't remember
the exact year but if I scroll down I
can see it it's 2021 which is correct so
here my opponent played G3
and there are other alternatives for
whites such as the move
I don't know E3 Knight F3 mainly played
like for example Knight C6 G3 and black
can respond with D5 playing some sort of
Sicilian more like a reversed dragon
with colors of course switched up but
there is also an interesting line
against that which has been appearing
more and more recently that I want to
show here white black can actually play
this move E4
although it looks like a very premature
attack and white can play Knight G5 to
attack the spawn black simply and
surprisingly plays this move
C6 and their idea is if allowed they
want to play D5 and defend the spawn and
the idea after takes takes takes black
goes D5 so black actually sacrifices
upon in return to get some initiative
immediately with the pieces and if they
play something like Knight H3 Knight G3
sorry I think black even responds with
the move H5 and I will just double check
that we are on the correct territory and
I'm looking at the games in this
position and it confirms that this
position has been played many times at
the top level and it's a very unique way
of playing because after white responds
with E3 black can simply go H4 and this
position is very exciting I would say to
play with black already out of the
opening so
this is one way to play but of course my
opponent didn't play Knight F3 so we're
going to go all the way back
to move number three
so C4 E5 Knight C3 Knight F6 and here my
opponent played G3 kind of dodging all
of those lines
and
I have been playing this line pretty
much
um very regularly myself so I played D5
cd5 Knight D5
Bishop G2
Knight B6 and here my opponent played E3
I played Knight C6 and my opponent
played Knight two
Knight G to E2
and this is probably the
uh
a critical moment I would say of the
game because
there are many ways to play here with
black but I think I have a very concrete
choice of what I would like to play with
the black pieces so
I'm going to I guess ask the chat and
also the in person
audience
what would you play here with with the
black pieces
so and a question in the chat is after
cd5 the C6 Pawn sacrifice
the C6 spawn sacrifice sound
so I'm guessing you are referring to the
previous line and you want to sacrifice
I mean you're referring to the pawn
sacrifice if it's sound it is sound yeah
that line is actually Oh you mean after
oh you're asking here if you can play C6
I don't think so this is too much I mean
I know the title is saying aggressive
way but I don't want to sacrifice pawns
just like that you know so
I get the point it's in the spirit but
it's preferable if we back it up with
some compensation like in the other one
we're chasing the Knight or something in
this case it's a little
um
it's a little
premature
Okay so
Smith Mora colors reversed yes but you
don't get the same number of uh
opportunities I would say because Smith
Mora you are already down upon so black
and if they know what they're doing they
can equalize and here you're down a
Tempo end up on it's
it's probably not going to work out
right so it's black to play here
I am curious about what the suggestions
will be of course probably is if I'm
asking I'm giving away a lot of things
but
let's just see if if
you can play Knight before but what's
your idea what night before you want
deep squares
yeah so also in the chat the night
before is suggested so if I go night
before what I'm slightly worried about
is my opponent will just castle and
if I try something like this which feels
like it's in the spirit of position I am
slightly worried because I am trying to
do something there but my opponent might
just block me
and kind of shut my Bishop down and if I
just go somewhere else I'm just wasting
too much time giving up the control of
the center so I probably don't want to
go Bishop F5 so maybe I want to jump
Knight to D3 but what next after I
achieve Knight on D3 I doubt I want to
take this bishop because I just played
one two three and potentially four moves
to capture something that has never
moved while I have my Bishops waiting my
king uncastled and I've just been moving
with the Knight chasing something and
here in fact my opponent can start
launching an attack on the king side and
the center
and this is probably not something I
want with the King that is not fully
developed yet so
94 93 is very tempting but if I am in
time I should be doing such things
um but yeah it's it's an interesting
idea for sure I would say any other
suggestions also it was the suggestion
in chat so I think that was
that's probably the first thing that
comes to mind
also now that I'm thinking after night
before white can also play D4 not even
allowing any jumps on Knight on D3
because if Bishop F5 there's E4 so
unfortunately we wouldn't be achieving
too much and after A3 we would be kicked
out
Bishop C5 is suggested that is an
interesting move controlling the D4
Square
I guess it's possible yeah they would
Castle
and we would cancel and the game would
probably
go on like this it's definitely an
alternative
that is not what I went for there there
are actually very similar ideas instead
of Bishop C5 I have played this move in
my life before after castles castles
this is something I have played
um but after F4 I wasn't really fully
enjoying these types of positions
because
um my opponent after takes takes very
nicely got a center and although the
game ended in a draw I was still not
happy happy to to give up the center
like that so over the course of years I
actually as the theory also developed I
adopted the following move H5
the idea being I simply want to play H4
and potentially take here if the king is
there or maybe just go H3 and try to
restrict this bishop on G2
so here my opponent responded with the
move H3 you might be curious about why
not H4 but as soon as you put your Pawn
on H4 you are somewhat uh weakening this
G4 Square which means that I can pretty
much anytime play my Bishop to G4 I am
very rarely scared of you playing F3
because now you just shut down your
Bishop for no good reason and the moment
you commit to something like F4 I can
always just put back to my bishop and it
will be just Untouchable I'm just
showing this as an example not as a move
by move Force line but that's kind of
something interesting and also the
moment you put your opponent H4 you're
always subject to attacks like G5 in the
long run especially if you want to
Castle short so that's why my opponent
played the move
H3 in this position okay so we started
with the H Pawn I think we have to
continue with the H Pawn it makes just
enough sense and after my opponent plays
G4 I think this is another
interesting move and this kind of shows
how computers actually changed chess
because in in the older times I would
say it's very rare you would see players
go H5 H4 and then even my next move I
think
my next move probably would be evaluated
as a strategic error maybe like 20 30
years ago but now it actually makes a
lot of sense since the computer is just
approve uh the play
so what would you play here with
um
with black
and I will definitely say why I think it
would be considered a strategic mistake
although I think it's not but
it's my personal preference
rather than
anything else
absolutely F5 since we started the king
side attack early we should actually
just go for it completely and the reason
I say this would be considered the
Strategic mistake is now I have
completely gave up this control of the
E4 square and I have actually a somewhat
isolated Pawn in the middle of the board
because I cannot control this Square by
any means and therefore
anytime my opponent can take advantage
of this it will actually be a problem so
my opponent played the move d4 here
I captured
they captured with the Knight
I captured again
and they took with the pawn so now the
E4 square is
um
not big of not really a deal but
it's more like my king is getting opened
up and also I have a pawn that is
hanging in the position
and
um
and I have to take care of some things
here so let's think about it what would
we play here with black
someone in the chat says your opponent
had no chance of beating you his ELO is
lower than yours right I mean I just
translated that in a in a nice way
um well I mean you shouldn't just look
at the rating right it's it's not only
about the rating it's more about
um the day and how you're feeling and
all that but I appreciate the the
confidence in my abilities
but I respect everyone and their rating
so I don't judge opponents by by ratings
all right so it's black to play I am
seeing C6 I am seeing Queen E7 so let's
discuss them
I don't like Queen E7
uh as much because after Bishop E3 now I
am no longer able to develop my Bishop
comfortably because my queen is blocking
I do however have the opportunity to
cast along but there is a drawback to
this move and um I hope that it's gonna
be obvious after I show the move Queen
to F3 attacking the bishop attacking the
pawn and I am not very happy with my
position actually black is probably
simply last year so I cannot do that
although I urgently want to castle since
my king is in the middle of the board so
Queen E7 was out of the question for me
especially because after this and if I
play something like C6 I'm still not
having the best position ever because my
opponent can Castle long or short get a
rook to the E file and my queen and my
king they're aligned although I will be
castleing long in no time I still don't
feel safe and definitely not active
enough
C6 would definitely be a good move or
natural move but the only concern I
think I had in the game is it being not
super fast enough I just thought that I
don't value this Pawn on B7 enough
to waste my time with C6 which is
usually my strategy when I'm playing
Dynamic chess ideally
if I can just get away with giving up
pieces and just continue developing
um that's what I will do so I played
Bishop E7 what's my idea I simply want
to Castle and I don't really mind my
opponent taking on B7 so of course I was
kind of provoking my opponent to take
but now I have to
um kind of justify my reasoning here
so
I guess if I ask what would you play in
this position everyone will find the
move but I will still do it so what
would you play here with black
which
probably has a reason behind me asking
and hence no one will ever suggest Rook
B8
but
I did not play Rook B8 which would
probably be the most natural move
because your Rook is being attacked but
the chat is right they are saying Castle
which is what I did sacrifice The Rook
give up everything in the name of
attacking your opponent
and if I move the Rook they are rightly
so saying Bishop C6 check and my
canceling rights might be uh damaged but
also
um
I don't want to retreat I don't like
retreating in chess this is the last
thing I like to do so I would rather
give up a pawn and The Rook than Retreat
this is the player I always wanted to be
and that's kind of the way I'm playing
is this sound a sacrifice is actually
approved by the computer so I think that
is the first question to be answered
does it actually make sense tactically
it does
um do I remember every single idea
um not really but
yeah this is actually pretty good so
just let's see what happens after he
goes Rook G1 I don't quite remember but
I think I can just
take here
I think and then I just want to put the
bishop on F6 if you try to do something
um
and I'm defending everything and I have
an outside fast pawn and my opponent is
underdeveloped as the chat is mentioning
so this is full compensation in fact I
will actually take a peek at the
computer analysis to see what's the eval
of this current position it started at
plus one point something and it went all
the way straight down to zero zero which
considering I'm looking at a computer it
doesn't surprise me and I actually
remember correct Rook G1 and Bishop
takes H3 is the first line of the
computer and the computer doesn't
disappoint by giving zero zero
everywhere
um even though I was feeling very
confident that I had a very good
position at this moment so
in the game my opponent did not take
my
my rook and played the move Bishop to E3
so I played Rook B8 now so there is no
more check on
C6 so I can finally confidently play
Rook B8 my opponent retreated their
Bishop back and here I played a nice
move I would say so I will just give it
back to the chat
um
what would you play here with black
so Knight C4 is a very tempting move but
there is a flaw to it unfortunately
yes it's pointed out in the chat
much
I will give you a chance to find the
flow of that move
so what is the drawback of Knight C4 it
kind of vacates this Square so if I do
that
I will unfortunately be losing the
Knight
so there is actually this funny thinking
mechanism in chess
which is saying that
whenever you make a move you actually
let go of the control of some square and
this is guaranteed like even if it's a
random move even if you Castle short for
example your king no longer controls
this square or like your Rook doesn't
control the H file so like every single
move has a drawback whether it's good or
not it doesn't mean sometimes much but
in this scenario that logic actually
works the Knight C4 would actually
evacuate this square and that would lose
so I see the chat suggested by Dennis in
the chat Queen D7 why did I play Queen
D7 well let's understand if you were
playing with the white pieces in this
situation what would you do and probably
generally speaking you would like to
Castle
so I play Queen D7 anticipating my
opponent castling short
and then I would just take on H3
and I would just be on top so I don't
want to waste too much time of on this
game so I will go a little bit faster
because there is one more game and I
think that's my favorite game on this
opening so
I just wanted to show this idea of
sacrificing The Rook playing some
compensation H5 H4 but the game the rest
of the game actually played out I would
say quite nicely for me so my opponent
played Queen E2 I immediately saw a uh
file opportunity a battery opportunity
on the e-file so I played Rook E8 with
the idea maybe to go Bishop G5 if I need
to
and maybe somehow prepare this Knight C4
not immediately to put some pressure on
the bishop on E3 so my opponent played
Rook D1 of course keep in mind my
opponent cannot Castle short the H3 Pawn
is hanging so they have to solve that
issue and also if they cast along
while I would be a little afraid because
now the B file is completely open and
anything is possible on the B file so
they have to be always watching out for
some discovery of this Knight and of
course there's Bishops coming and nobody
wants to deal with that so my opponent
just played Rook D1 just simply getting
the Rook out of the way and I played
Bishop G5 keep in mind they cannot still
Castle played Queen F3 and it was at
this moment I kind of took took and
played Rook f8 so I am still not
allowing them to play castles why
because if they Castle I actually can
make use of the f file by playing Bishop
D3
um then is the same could Rook B to E8
be better so your suggestion is could
this move be better you are saying Rook
B E8 it could be better but I am also
anticipating my opponent from castling
and I want to Bluff him on the B file at
least not Bluff I mean I'm just having
an activity on the B file so arguably
after seeing the game maybe my Rook
should have belonged to f8 but my
opponent doesn't necessarily have to
play the exact same moves they did so
the situation required me to go back to
f8 and I can potentially play Rook B8
be8 now given that I have the option of
doing that so actually in the rook in
the game my opponent played Rook D2 and
then I played Rook B8 so castles is not
an option still because I have Bishop D3
attacking the queen attacking the rook
and there is no good move for my
opponent this doesn't do anything this
is not possible because the Knight
defense I win an exchange and then I
will slowly win the game so Rook B8 my
opponent Castle I did actually play
Bishop D3 and they did end up
sacrificing the queen for
a rook and the bishop and they also have
a pawn but this is just not enough in
terms of compensation because
my pieces are going to get coordinated
in no time which they did I played
Knight D5 and I just moved around a
little bit I'm preventing my opponent
from playing E4 as I will meet that with
Knight F4
and then I was allowed to enter and
create a sufficient play I will just go
till the end but here white just doesn't
have enough counter play towards my
pieces and I just collected everything a
couple more moves and they just resigned
because the Knight is hanging
so that was it for this game
um of course there can be a lot of
discussion after my opponent sacrificed
the queen but I think the pressure was
just getting to them and they couldn't
figure out and of course time was
ticking too time is a factor in an
actual game time is ticking pressure is
there the Rooks are looking at you and
that's why they were like okay I'm gonna
sack the queen and hope that my minor
pieces can do something but it's not
enough once you get some play with the
queen and the Knight they are super well
coordinated
um
and that would just be over so now we're
gonna go and see my next game which is
definitely my most uh favorite game in
this opening I will just flip the board
um
and kind of discuss it so we're talking
about the English opening and if you
have missed it also I see in the
comments Miss 30 minutes you can always
watch the first 30 minutes the next day
so that should be completely fine and in
this game
my opponent played this very lesser
played move d4 the main moves in this
position are E3 G3 even D3
A3 and E4 all of these moves are played
a lot compared to move d4 but when I Was
preparing against my opponent I actually
saw that he is a very strong
correspondence chess player at the same
time
and correspondence chess is basically
the type of Chess where
um you are allowed to use computer
software to play the game both com both
parties actually can use computer but
they also need a human Insight sometimes
as it's not just computers by themselves
and also keep in mind my opponent is a
regular Grandmaster so unlike the last
game this game I'm playing the Grand
Master so I have to be very careful but
since this was preparation and I saw
that my opponent plays this line I
actually was able to prepare something
very sharp and very concrete against the
system
here my I took my opponent took and I
immediately played Bishop B4
and this is of course the most played
move also in the computer chess because
I have an engine too and I'm preparing
using an engine so I wasn't shocking my
opponent by any means uh in the earlier
stages of the game in fact I will
probably pull up the opening book just
to get an idea of how much it was played
and Bishop B4 in the leeches database
has been played 87
this is the Masters like in actual chess
games has been played 87 percent of the
time so it's actually not a surprise at
all so my opponent plays Bishop G5 also
the most typical move and here I played
the move H6 and H6 played 82 percent of
the time so I'm always playing the top
moves well you might say like okay
you're playing the top moves he's
playing the top moves how are you even
gonna get an edge especially if your
opponent constantly plays this line and
this is my literally first time
to be even honest I didn't know this
move existed before I started preparing
against my opponent which is funny and
that's the day of the game so I don't
have too much time and I have never seen
this move in my life and granted I know
he plays C4 but I can choose from
different lines against them
but I and I have no idea what to do
against this and this is something he
plays all the time so I regardless went
for it because I had a very clever idea
that I thought would have worked and if
I'm showing the game it's clearly worked
right so they showed before
Bishop G5 H6
Bishop H4 and here was the critical
moment of
the line and I'm trying to remember the
nuances here
it is black to play
and I didn't play the top move of the
engine and not the top move that is
played either so that already started to
surprise him a little bit I would say
so what would you hear play with black
and what do you think is the top move
even of the engine
not the engine necessarily but human
play
because I don't know the engine might
have changed his mind
so suggestion number one is Knight E4
but Knight E4 would just hang the queen
although you're still making me think
because Knight E4 Bishop d8 Knight C3
might be your argument but I think
even if they move the queen
actually there's Knight D4 here hold on
a second that's interesting
Queen D3
well there's 94.
what is this move
there's no way Knight E4 works
what
crazy this is too crazy there is no way
this works though
Knight C6 is suggested in the chat no no
no Knight C6 okay actually Knight C6
yeah good because the bishop is hanging
so if you take here I take there I don't
need to be up a queen yeah that's
correct so I can also be up a piece to
win the game
especially if they're a grandmother so
here it's already like well what happens
if it takes well at least we got rid of
the Knight then I can just move the
queen this is this is over yeah we can't
do that that was okay that was an
accidental Adventure but I respect
everyone's move so we gotta take a look
at them Knight E5 looks interesting it
does look interesting but
um
it's moving the same piece twice maybe I
can get with get away with that argument
but it looks interesting I guess you can
just go E3 though so defending the spawn
but it's definitely still something that
has to be considered I just don't want
to play something like this you know
because they're gonna take and they're
just gonna develop
um so so there are G5 suggestions in
multiple positions so let's try to look
at all of them so G5 here is possible
so Bishop e G3 and I'm gonna guess that
whoever suggests G5 they want to jump 94
on the next move because they don't want
to give up the queen but after something
like Rook C1 I'm not sure how I take
advantage of the knights being pinned
and of course
I also had to consider Bishop takes E5
in this position which almost was missed
by me but I think this position would
just be lost for uh for black because I
don't have enough pieces simply and if I
go F6 even
there is potentially Rook C1 but also
this should be sufficient because
this is not enough
upon on the safe two Bishops I mean
Knight and Bishop versus Rook it's not
enough
so 95 playing with the same piece I'm
not a huge fan of that G5 Bishop G3 this
is I think A variation definitely played
um it was actually played by Georges
versus Mikhail tal in 1974. so that
shows you that this line actually exists
and if Knight E4 I guess white just goes
Queen D3 and this was exactly the tall
game and I think I remember this
checking this line
and here tall plate Knight B5 which
looks interesting I don't know if it's
necessary though so this is what they
did tell did this and putting pressure
there he eventually won the game so I
wasn't too happy with the earlier G5 and
also we have to keep in mind my opponent
probably knows what to do after G5 it's
kind of
too obvious
I am seeing Jared is saying C5 instead I
am not sure at what moment you are
referring to C5 but you're probably
referring to it in a moment like
this
here's C5
but also I'm checking the computer it
says Queen B3 not the computer but the
um the online database every almost
everyone played Queen B3 here attacking
the bishop probably going A3 next move
even if you go something like A5 so I'm
not really a big fan of just giving up
the bishop like this I gave up the
bishop pair I couldn't even ruin the
pawn structure
so actually the main line in this
position is Bishop takes C3 the argument
is that black ruins the pawn structure
and then
and then they go Knight E5 with the idea
to basically
play against this weekend Pawns
um and I guess after E3 this would
transpose to the previous thing we were
seeing but the main idea as far as I
have seen from my opponent's games is
actually white plays this move F4
sacrificing the pawn on C4 because if
you take on C4 I believe white can
continue with some expansion like E4
attacking this guy trying to go E5 and
if this happens unfortunately this
lecture would not be happening it would
be more like
Adventure like aggressive play with
white in the
English opening so for this to happen
um I shouldn't be allowing any of that
and I don't generally like although this
was the most played uh
although this is the most played line I
um
I don't usually like to play with the
same piece twice or multiple times in
reality so what I did was I actually
just simply castled
instead of taking the Knight on C3
my opponent played E3
I just played rookie simply improving my
pieces and here my opponent played
Rook to
C1
and this is the basically the critical
moment of
of the game
it is
like to play and this is where basically
my preparation deviated for the from not
it didn't deviate yet but it will start
deviating very soon from the most played
line
so it's black to play
and
let's see what the general public ones
if my opponent would ever capture on C6
I would have always taken with the B
Pawn
take it towards the center and then go
D5
um
and just control the
the center even more
so D5 is also suggested in the chat and
it's a pretty interesting move I would
say so D5
if I take your idea is probably to take
and get to a position that we sort of
discussed and I would say it kind of
makes sense
I just don't know how to proceed after
Bishop E2
I guess that brings us to the point they
should have probably taken on C6 but
um it's very important when should they
have done it because their last move was
Rook C1 so maybe after if they took on
C6 here maybe it's a good idea to first
throw in Bishop takes C3 check and then
take like this so that their Pawn
structure is also ruined I might do
something like this go D5 but in the
game
if I played D5 Knight takes takes and
then Bishop E2 I rarely want to take on
C3 because now they can take with the
rook and I'm not I'm not fully satisfied
at least with the opening outcome so I
didn't want to do that but I think D5 is
actually played no D5 is not quite
played a lot but yeah it's definitely a
move
so here I actually took they took and
then
I played
yeah someone is suggesting
g594 yeah you can do that too
but I'm not threatening much right they
can just play this
I don't want to take the bishop ever
because that would just open up the H
file
and they want to cancel
I don't know I just opened my king too
much I cannot exploit anything so I
don't really like that uh I did this to
myself
so what I did is I took on D4 they took
and here I played the mob G5
what majority of the games played
however is 62 percent which is a lot of
percent compared to the others is the
move C5
and the idea of all of them was
basically to I mean I guess do the same
thing I did they got G5 Bishop G3 and
this is where the roads kind of
um went different ways so the most
common move in this position played by
almost every single player is the move
D5 and the reason is you just want to do
something quick and you want to control
the center and it makes a lot of sense
but this wouldn't be a surprise to my
opponent because he would just take on
D5 and almost everyone plays Queen takes
D5 why well if Knight takes D5 white can
simply develop Bishop B5 and in fact
there is a game of Yasser Sarah one
played in the 1999 I was like one years
old at that time and unfortunately he
was on the black side and
he lost the game against thatchnik very
strong Grandmaster and this would lead
to some sort of an end game that's kind
of what happened in their game and white
eventually won this but I really don't
want to play an end game I don't really
want to play Queen takes D5 either
because after it takes takes Bishop B5 I
mean I'm not so sure I achieved anything
out of my preparation if I even prepared
all this so I had to come up with
something different and this is where my
thinking process as well as using the
computer helped me in this position so
it is
um black to play and what would you do
with
this position
Queen A5 is a suggestion
well if you go Queen A5
I guess
um
I guess you are not really threatening
much right
I can just develop I I guess you can
take though so Queen A5 is a serious
suggestion
Queen A5 and what is our idea if okay I
understand what your idea is if I go A3
you just want to take and if Knight
takes our Rook takes you want to jump
Knight E4 and what's the point if I go
here
I'm gonna guess that you definitely want
to take on A2 because it's a free Pawn
that's a fair that's a fair argument
um
Queen B3 might be a nice move though
kind of preventing you from taking the
pawn
yeah the chat is actually starting to
get the book they have to move so as you
all saw D5 led to some trade in the
center and it traded into some sort of
end game but I really don't want my
opponent to take my Pawn I like the idea
of D5 but if I really want to get the D5
push maybe I should actually try to not
do that but go back to the game real
quick
which I did it in a different move order
I played G5 first and then C5 and after
this here I played the move B5
and the idea of B5 is I'm dynamically
responding towards my opponent's Center
and I actually want to take on C4 so
let's say they play something like
um Bishop E2
I take they take and then I go D4 D5
with the idea to go D4 and I can
actually create something dynamic in the
position and if they play something like
this
um
there is something like
D4 and yeah that's that should be just
doing great for me I think and even if I
don't Sacrifice by the way position
should be should be incredibly Dynamic
and it should be a lot of fun to do it
but I think this is correct takes
I I can take I'm even actually
calculating if I can do this
sack the queen
take
there
under promote to a night
check
because your king can only wait this is
not good oh actually it's good
that's pretty smart you have to go to a
light Square if you go here that's mate
it's pretty nice
that would be nice if you go here I go
check
pick up your queen on d8 if you go here
I check you unfortunately Bishop B5
check would not help since I can take
um so this would be a pretty mate also
I'm just freestyling right now I'm not
even thinking at anything so maybe this
was interesting actually
I think it works out
although he can take here
that was that was nice while it lasted
but I guess it doesn't quite work I mean
it works in the sense that I can take
if you take with the Rook I take on C3
take on E8 if you take what the king I
can go here
I'm attacking these two pieces so it's
still still alive a bishop E2 I'm not
very sure what the best move was but if
I remember correctly
something along the lines of Queen D6 at
some point was right but I don't
remember yeah computer says A3 is the
best move which is what my opponent did
I played Bishop A5 and then Queen D6
here is the the best move which my
opponent didn't play
um or Bishop E2 yeah Bishop E2 bc4 Queen
D6 was the best move to not allow the
pawn to go to D5 but this is not really
human it's very difficult to play Such
most because you are tempting me to play
an id4 and only then you can play
something like Queen D5 this is very
difficult a human doesn't usually Play
Moves Like Queen D6 with the idea to
provoke Knight E4 and then go Queen D5
so my opponent took on B5 but after that
it was actually quite simple I played D5
they played Bishop E2 and by the way
they barely had any time left because
they tanked for so long they have never
seen the move B5 although they have
played this line for so many times they
were in complete shock and after I
played this
they played B4 and it's not so difficult
for me to calculate here because I can
just simply take and take and the pin on
that Knight is just quite brutal and my
opponent just basically started
collapsing From This Moment onwards
um well the main problem I guess is if
you take e takes D4 I can always go
Knight E4 and gang up on this piece and
win it and if you do queen takes D4 it's
not going to be any different I will
just take take and then go 94 and then I
can just win this night
my opponent here played Bishop F3 I
guess it's a nice uh idea to think about
in this position what would you play
here with
um with black and there is a question in
the chat so let's address that and then
we can go back to the to the game so the
question is instead of Bishop E2 could
white play B4 he definitely could have
but I guess I take and I take and it's
kind of tough to
um
to get out of this pin in this situation
as well I am threatening Knight E4
probably your suggestion also works
totally fine but I am trying to remember
what my opponent might have missed in
the game
um
I think this is what my opponent
actually missed here
he was thinking of playing B4 C before a
before Bishop B4 and then Queen yeah
yeah this is good this is good
suggestion my opponent was thinking of
playing Queen D4 here with the idea to
actually attack the bishop and then hope
to play Bishop E2 castles and thanks for
that question actually that's great I
almost forgot mentioning this line but
there is a very nice idea here for black
to kind of take advantage of the peace
placement and to win the game so how
would black win
um in this position here
that's great
great line on the line I guess two moves
Rook E4 very nice so I have the Rook E4
the queen has to depart somewhere
anywhere and then I can go D4 and this
guy's pinned and that's game over so I'm
taking advantage of the pin and the pin
on many pins
and he cannot do anything in this
situation
um
even if they go Bishop E2 or something
it looks like I cannot take here that's
correct but I'm pretty sure we can find
um
something like Queen A5 here
attack the knights multiple times and
that would be the end of the game
so yeah that was not possible I think
that was the main intention of going C
takes B5 but it's just not in time so
this had to happen in the game and here
my opponent played Bishop F3 so how do
we
um how do we potentially
win in this situation
yeah I'm just like double checking the
lines but yeah it's it's correct yeah
just wanted to make sure I remember
everything right
Bishop C3 Rook C3 Queen A5
Bishop C3 Rook C3 Queen A5 but that
loses actually to Queen takes D4
if you do that Queen takes D4 and that's
gonna be end of the game
so I see D takes C3 being suggested but
what do you do after Queen takes Rook
takes and then Bishop takes A8
what do you do there
so DC3 is interesting but you are losing
The Rook on A8 and um what would you do
in that situation
Queen A5 is another suggestion so after
this queen A5 is being suggested but the
problem is you are always giving up the
pawn on D4 so the moment you play Queen
A5 you lose this Pawn
so we get
we were talking about DC3 Queen takes
Rook takes
94 In This Moment yeah so 94 is a
recommendation okay let's think about
that and if I take
it take with the rook and now you are at
you are saying that I can't take the
Rook which is correct
but how about I do that then I pin your
Pawn towards your queen
so now my idea is if you take what the
pawn I take your queen and if you take
my knight I actually take and this time
I am taking advantage of the Pawn on D4
being pinned and once again somehow
white escaped miraculously
so Knight E4 is unfortunately not
sufficient either I think we are right
on the track with taking the night
and then taking here giving up the
exchange but we just have to see a last
couple of moves in this position so C2
is being recommended
and after King E2
I see Bishop E6 as a recommendation
which is pretty strong I would say but
after yeah Rook takes C2 we kind of give
up this Pawn although I would probably
still say black is favorable I still
don't see the
end of the game just yet I mean yes it's
winning you can go here and you can just
grab the pawn at some point and then
push your Pawn down the board but to me
that still work to be done which I think
there is a much more clear-cut way in
this position that is in front of us
rather than
um
doing it that way so
Rook D2 check excellent if King goes up
I have Bishop G4 mate we have seen this
mate actually earlier in the position or
earlier in the game
and after King goes to F1 now it's
important how do we finish the game off
how do we finish off this game
Bishop E6 is possible yeah anything is
possible actually but there is a much
more
simpler move I guess Rook D1 is yeah
it's definitely a good move but opponent
goes King E2
and
still not the end of the game okay you
say Rook takes H1 I go Rook takes H1
okay how is this winning xiaomi
still not resigns like still my opponent
has some defense
um
so
okay
so Bishop A3 is being suggested I'm not
sure if it's in this position or the
initial one but if you go Bishop A3
let's say here I just go King D2 and if
you even promote
then yeah okay you say Bishop A3 before
but this would not be winning actually
this would be losing because I mean
almost losing
so
as it was suggested we do not need to
rush and try to win in a very quick
manner or anything I can just simply
Play Bishop A3 and I believe it was this
position when my opponent
resigned because there is no way out of
this position even if they take on C2 I
just take I'm up a piece this is very
easy to win
um and therefore he returned so this
this game is the game I wanted to show
and it's kind of brilliant because in
this position players like Barre of
course noi chernin rublevsky almost all
of them Yasser Sarah one
and many others they have played the
move D5 here it was only me and one more
player and that was after me uh actually
no that was right before me one month
before me played this move
B5
and the rest actually followed the trend
of playing D5 played an end game and
white scores were quite decent I would
say uh in those end games because
and actually I'm looking at it there is
only one zero one the rest is like
either a draw or one zero so that kind
of shows how dominant this line kind of
was but after this B5 I don't see anyone
ever playing it in the recent years so I
think this line will probably never be
repeated
um
and
yeah that should be the end of this line
at least until until further notice so
well hopefully
that was fun to watch
um I think that's going to be the end of
the lecture
and yeah thank you for watching
and I guess I'll see you all next time
yeah thank you thank you
[Music]